hey guys it's me angelia welcome back to
my channel today i'm going to show you
how i do things in my orbit on my own
youtube star adelia rose williams has
died she was just 15 years old according
to an announcement made on her instagram
account the youtuber who had hutchinson
guilford syndrome died on wednesday
night in the caption williams family
wrote in part quote january 12 2022 at 7
pm adelia rose williams was set free
from this world she came into it quietly
and left quietly but her life was far
from it she touched millions of people
and left the biggest imprint in everyone
that knew her the post continued quote
she is no longer in pain and is now
dancing away to all the music she loves
according to the mayo clinic hutchinson
guilford syndrome is an extremely rare
progressive genetic disorder that causes
children to age rapidly starting in
their first two years of life heart
problems or strokes are the eventual
cause of death in most children with the
disorder and the average life expectancy
is about 13 years today we're heading to
the hospital
williams has more than 2.9 million
subscribers on youtube and was known for
posting makeup tutorials okay so
today i'm going to be doing eyeliner
because this is the most requested video
you guys wanted me to do
i like you anything for you guys
you guys are spoiled vlogs with her
family okay here we are dr seuss land
you're scared
no why
you don't want to get wet and other life
updates today we're going to be cooking
with our dad um
morning
you should have supervision
with your parents in november williams
posted her second to last video on the
platform and with the help of her mom
natalia the teen explained why she
hadn't been posting as much hey guys
i'm so i haven't been making any videos
i have some bad bagging
do you want me to tell them
i thought he lost her hearing about
um i think like maybe three months ago
she got really sick
yeah she lost her hearing and it hasn't
returned so
oh and she can read my lips
so
and she's a really good lip reader
williams is survived by her parents ryan
and natalya and her three brothers
marcelo nico and emiliano i hope you
guys enjoy
bye
you